Speaker 1: there is more paper trail where
because of newly released emails we have
learned in the last 24 hours that Donald Trump and
his administration were pressuring the Department
of Justice to challenge the election results
of the 2020 election to try to help Trump stay
in power. This is it's just every day is more.
The New York Times reports that an hour before
President Donald Trump announced in December that
William Barr would step down as attorney general,
the president began pressuring Mr. Barr's eventual
replacement to have the Justice Department take
up his false claims of election fraud. Trump
sent an email via his assistant, Jeffrey Rosen,
the incoming I'm sorry, via his assistant, to
Jeffrey Rosen, the incoming acting attorney
general, containing documents purporting to show
evidence of election fraud in northern Michigan.
The same claims that a judge had thrown out
a week earlier in a lawsuit filed by one of
Trump's personal lawyers. Another email from
Trump to Mr. Rosen followed two weeks later,
again via the president's assistant. That
included a draft of a brief that Mr. Trump
wanted the Justice Department to file to the
Supreme Court. It argued, among other things, that
state officials had used the pandemic to weaken
election security and pave the way for widespread
election fraud. It simply will not stop. It's
another example of Donald Trump abusing his power
as president to try to strong arm people to steal
the election for him. It's that simple, and that's
the language we should use about it. Trump called
the Georgia election officials remember Secretary
of State Brad Raffensperger and others and said,
we just need to find eleven thousand seven hundred
and eighty votes, that's all. And then Donald
Trump had Rudy Giuliani all over the country
pushing all sorts of bogus nonsense. And now we
learn Trump was pressuring the Justice Department
to help him in doing the exact same. It is
really time to start prosecuting members of
the Trump administration, if not Trump himself.
There's just no other option here. And of course,
if they did it, it would be called out as
completely partizan by the Republican Party.
But if this in some total doesn't warrant
prosecution, what does is quite, quite literally.
If we don't prosecute over this, we're going back
to that Nixon idea of if the president does it,
it's not illegal. Remember how many investigations
and hearings they had about Benghazi that they
successfully were able to hold in order to try to
hurt Hillary Clinton politically. And now look at
what's going on. Now, some of you might say this
is just too much, even for Trump supporters.
Finally, it's just everything's coming
up. The Trump supporters are finally
going to be convinced to abandon Donald Trump
because of this or because of the next thing.
No way. Now, they will say the report is fake news
or they will say, well, no, Trump had to do it
because it was Biden who stole the election from
him. So Trump had to go to the Justice Department
and to lobby the Supreme Court to give him the
election because Biden is the one who stole it.
And guys, these are the people who when the power
went out in Texas because of that isolationist
right wing decision to totally separate the
Texas power grid from the rest of the country.
These are the right wingers who said the
reason the power went out is wind power. It's
frozen windmills. That's the explanation for
them. The ends justify the means. And if they
simply believe that Donald Trump had to do it to
stop Joe Biden from stealing the election and stop
Joe Biden's socialism, they don't care. They don't
care what Trump may have done or may have tried to
do to stay in power. So we it's been five years,
guys, where we say, oh, this this this they they
won't tolerate. Now they're going to. Nope. They
just look the other way or they excuse it. Now,
one other thing. There are people saying don't
prosecute Trump because of fears of violence.
If you prosecute Trump, it's going to trigger even
more violence on the streets. That may be true,
but it can't be the reason that this is not
pursued. It just can't be. Trump formed a
coalition of these ignorant and sometimes violent
people. He wepa weaponize their ignorance and
gullibility into the Trump riots and more, and
then he weaponize their gullibility into raising
tens of millions of dollars, supposedly to fight
this fraud and to fight that fraud and to recount
this and that. And then now we're going to say,
listen, they may become even more violent if we
do what we need to do, which is to actually
prosecute this. That can't happen. It simply
cannot be that. That's the reason why they're
all allowed to get away with it. And by the way,
won't they be emboldened in some sense if Trump
and everybody around Trump does end up skating
in the sense that they will have done all of
this huge list of things won't have succeeded
at getting Trump back in power, but they will
have done it all. This attempt, that attempt,
these lies, those bogus lawsuits, the January
six riots on and on and on, and no consequences
that will embolden them for the next
time and whether the next time is August.
Or 20, 22 or 20, 24, we don't yet know, but we
can't say now they're going to get violent if
we prosecute, so we can't do it, that that's
not how the United States of America works.